Welcome everybody.
Thank you for being part of the
first regional.
Session of the select committee
of intellectual developmental
disabilities.
Thank you Fresno for hosting us.
Who were anxiously awaiting his
arrival he?
Assemblymember thirty first
district for joining us this
evening.
I'll be brief.
Remarks.
Listen to you.
Not me.
Assemblymember Jim Frazier.
Aye represents the eleventh
assembly district the delta
region.
But I'm here today because I
chair of this committee.
Discuss.
It with intellectual and
developmental disabilities.
Thanks us all regardless of our
background [inaudible]
Is.
This a select committee on the
ID de movie is listening and
listening intently.
Doesn't concerns and suggestions.
On how we can improve.
Servicing the people we care.
For select.
Different from standing register
committees.
Some pending legislation but
legislation can happen.
With all of your input.
And that.
I really hope that you can give
us your input.
Help move the needle forward.
And I move forward.
I'm sorry.
The system did and how we can
improve moving forward.
Hey we have expressed our
respective fields testifying to
the rentals.
Program services and challenges.
But as we can test we will Rev
up for the next legislative
cycle as we wrap this one up.
Number eighty population
continues to grow and we need to
be able to provide support and
services that are essential to
this population.
So.
Without further ado.
I would to say that we should
get started on this.
Great.
Opportunity to meet each and
everyone of you.
Elvis taken around afterwards if
you have anything that you'd
like to add.
On the maybe you're just a
little bit bashful public or
just want to be in private I'm
more than happy to have a
discussion with.
Each any one of you until.
Thank you similar member Frazier
we're glad to have you and your
team here and are very positive --
For amber you're coordinating
efforts and bringing us all
together here and I understand
you're from Clovis highs so you
of the Central Valley connection
we appreciate that.
So -- I want
to say.
I'm gonna disclose some billing
stuff last year and commuters
Lecter their lives simply also
purpose capacidad often a lot
intellect Wallasey love.
Del Desiderio yes a person on
but I could not in store
pertaining died there scratch
about in bias and from.
An internal caps on us in the LA
Argentina can seven Espanol là
sympathetic and now I am in the
coming safe Rachel translator.
That appeals okay I on about
some of the Ana until becoming a
thing going.
On but I can see use that
assesses changing times --
We serve in the Central Valley
over nineteen thousand four
hundred individuals representing
six counties I do have a power
point [inaudible]
In.
The city California's you know
has made a commitment under the
Lanham act to serve people
throughout the state California
Rick.
Com um and so what will into
meant for individuals with
developmental the bill.
And their families I'm in other
states on their thing là this
other states if you don't
qualify for Medicaid you don't
answer.
Is.
On your own for families that
can be very challenging any
numbers such actions or they can.
One third of many things that
the rest of us take.
For the mobile. Seven for
members developmental
disabilities.
Until they got Irwin.
In and the that's the earn so
it's crucial.
Birth out our work that we do
that.
Members come from.
Some members come personal voice
found that we must attend.
To the service must either it's
I'm step.
Those are at stake graphic in
our area we have steps but not
often entity.
Talked with the state not aid in
teas and the reason for this was
that we are supposed to be
nimble and flexible to the needs
of our community.
And sometimes people get a
little frustrated because you go
between regional centers and
things might seem a little
different now services once you
receive them once you're found
eligible under the Lanham acts
so age three and up --
You should be eligible
throughout the state your
services should transfer between
regional centers.
In the not so distant past
regional centers what kind of
coral or bicker over the money
following the person and when
did that money got transferred
in the state.
Several years back made a change
where the regional centers are
true.
To at the end of the year so
they should be no more issues
around case transfers but I hear
that there are still some
challenges along those lines.
Our philosophy at CRC to the
greatest extent possible is just
take the case we need to get
families part of the services as
quickly as possible [inaudible]
I'm.
In the Central Valley we have
issues around transportation --
Lack of social opportunities
insufficient medical care
providers are airy our our needs
can be very different from the
needs of the rest of the state --
Because we don't have all these
connective tissue with bus lines
and and high speed rail yet you
know these things are coming and
I know that you're on the
transportation sub sub committee
and more to come transportation
is a huge issue in our area.
People --
Assume that we don't have
housing issues here in the
valley because we have lots of
land and because we're a low
income area but we have very
similar issues to other parts of
the state's.
We have a low capacity for
housing --
There is housing that is being
built for instance in Clovis but
Fresno had made some changes in
their housing and redevelopment
and zoning --
Look -- More
to come on that and I know that
that's not special instead is is
all [inaudible]
In.
Bedroom apartment what washer
and dryer the going rate the
theft and Dahle.
Which is a real I would consider
once in could be hundreds or
some.
Maybe nine hundred a month they
count of for other things if
trying to buy into a nice
neighborhood.
So they often in the
neighborhoods that are more
dangerous than they should be.
If can get in at all because we
in the back to get your about
ours than Marler.
What's in it is --
So you can see that will talk
about area Los Angeles there are
very different than ours if we
were to look assist as a whole.
We may miss some of needs
Central Valley of weren't
promote independence
employability care and support --
We also have to access generic
services this was an original
intent of the letterman act that
service coordination.
The doctor immune [inaudible]
Welcome.
Please proceed thank you.
I'm generic or services are
requirement of the regional
centers to access.
So first five insurance medi cal
funded services and school
districts are things we must
attend to before we can purchase
of service --
And with generic services
sometimes people get confused
about those --
But it will as I said it was an
original intent of Lanham act
that the regional centers are
service coordination entities.
And that was our first and
foremost I'm a borrowed from
Star Trek our prime directive --
Is service coordination so I
have a slight later that shows
you -- From
the complex systems that
families have to navigate and
our job is to try to help them
navigate complex systems.
I wanted to bring your attention
to community access services
that senior CS engaged in at
this time.
We have a promo toward community
navigator program which is
working with our Spanish
speaking among speaking
communities this is headed up by
my chief counselor ritual Hagens
who's in the back --
And these folks go into the
homes they talk with the
families about why they're not
accessing services and what
those.
Challenges are and we're
learning in some cultures --
Feel somewhat ashamed perhaps in
their community to have a family
member board of the
developmental disability.
But we didn't understand then
the deeper dive was even showing
up to their house called
attention to this and if you're
talking about a clown system for
instance this could change your
standing in the clown.
So it's very complex it's very
important we have those
community navigators helping us
on this is the program for
center of new Americans that
we've --
Contracted with.
I'm wearing gauging in person
center practices training for
all staff for our service
providers families and
individuals through Michael
small.
And I put a under liner rips and
a river Berman in the back also
helps us with the project.
In control compensate for all
staff at the for service for
your through doctor Valerie
about the vision ink we also
don't ting called.
Us and try to reach out to
understand that neighborhoods so
that we can have direct access
individuals and families
research here from their voice
directly.
These are just some examples of
how we're trying dressed in
meridian arc de.
These are examples of services
region centers provide spit care
in op is Dave programs.
Of schemes don't center one of
the things we take pride in an
at a rain my the mission back
there.
Started this night guys so you
won T..
Be helpful.
Answer phones twenty four seven
so we do not some people to
voice mail.
And one of the ages certainly
made.
A few to the desk you will be
routed to a real person for
intake and assessment this is a
well known and in some vantage
of the last.
Of the in it's a very important.
And a vote. 7% of the Chau pain
need services beyond early start
early intervention which is
really exciting number that I
just heard from one of our city
kids Clovis unified partners --
So I can go into detail with us
if you would like these are the
criteria we also have a handout
that was at the front table for
what the criteria are.
Now.
If you weren't confused before
for early start here are the
rules for age three through
adulthood.
So once a child begins to turn
three so you're not quite there
yet -- We
start assessing for went but
what we fondly call Lanham
eligibility.
And that's what you're mostly
clear with up to three calls to
lex just the in app lapsed and
then.
The fifth.
So there services.
Persons planes so similar to
support an election disability.
Or some some with.
With [inaudible]
Ability.
Do you have to have three out of
seven what they call stone the
regulations I hate using this
term but that's and regulations
substantially handicapping.
Conditions which must be met.
And thirty two thousand three
legislation you used to be able
to qualify with to out of seven
but it was a cost savings
measure by the state at that
time to increase the number of
substantial handicaps you must
have to get into the system.
Prior to that in two thousand
two there was a legislative
change.
Where the assessment period
moved from sixty days which was
the norm for linemen eligibility
to a hundred and twenty days --
So these are both cost savings
motor so sometimes we hear from
the community the frustration
around eligibility --
And we do have a team here --
Tammy Maranda his here to she's
our clinical Sir I'm about how
do you get into the system how
do you.
You know how do you how do you
get found eligible it all starts
with referral process --
Robust review of records as many
records as we can get from
school systems these sorts of
things.
And then --
If we need to will do our own
assessment using a psychologist
and then an interdisciplinary
team made up of a physician
psychologist the service
coordinator at Sutter will make
on decisions around eligibility
based on all the afraid of
available data and information.
One thing you're probably aware
of is starting an intake and
assessment all the way through
our service provision there's
always room for AA exceptions
and be.
Appeals.
And we are not opposed to
appeals in fact sometimes we
will encourage families to do
appeals because that will allow
a judge to make a decision in a
different direction.
Than maybe we feel we're allowed
to do by what's in regulation
are law.
But for families that can be a
burden that's just one more
thing for them to go through --
When you know when they're when
they're trying to get their
needs met and?
On for the way the laws are
written you know but I have
someone come in with
schizophrenia and that alone I'm
not going to be able to serve
them and that's really hard on
the family.
They come in and crisis and they
want us to serve them.
And we have to tell them now so
our job is a community is a
collaborative community in
partnership with exceptional
fair parents unlimited.
And our other community partners
six EP you exceptional parents
unlimited as our family resource
center --
Hand offs together and make sure
that people get plugged into the
services they need so they're
not just told you're not
eligible and move on with your
life.
And we really try to help
families are in crisis even if
we're not that person for on I'm
these are examples of services
we provide birth to three I just
want to draw to your attention
in.
Two thousand nine there was
legislation passed that no
longer allow us to provide space
for in some top players.
Is a full the feet third.
Member.
Of baby.
A ticket their baby in a person
time I'm not fine out have you
ever.
Care take first.
Family member who maybe wasn't
hot.
Or in on this. One when you're.
In first when you're on the
phone or seven or take burn out
they've [inaudible]
My gosh --
Formally included in --
School age --
Was also --
Suspended services such as
social recreation in camp --
In age twenty three and up we
work on employability housing
medical support and quirk.
That map of telling you about
earlier to get permission.
For post this.
Man this is around.
She's served area but I'm
assuming full of comp since the
fan is half now but it.
Room regional planner is opposed
to be to help family now very
complex systems --
And you can see when you look at
the health care systems
education systems all these
sorts of things that families
must get engaged with that this
can be very complex and
challenging for them and
whatever we can do to simplify
their lives it's really
imperative --
So systems challenges in our
service leader.
The river centers tomorrow we
was up for one and all center
for every million residents so
we have four regional center
state and by the math the
relaxation stopped at twenty one
each.
Other's so about services
service coordination and the
ability to meet family's needs
and have time for them you know
these are some areas that you
might want to look up.
Systems challenge an adequately
funded provider rates the
provider rate study that's
upcoming is a great opportunity.
To look at these sorts of things
but we've also had rate freezes
legislative mandates for uniform
holiday schedules finally called
forced closure days.
And half day billing --
Which has severely impacted our
providers their ability to hire
keep and retain staff and
provide quality services.
Providers and I also including
providers to see you know the
concept of para professionals
parents are professionals in the
care of their own children.
And many of them are highly
specialized especially in the
medical and behavioral care of
their children.
So there are services that we
funded that support the family
reckless and serve as context
and there's an optional.
I'm not on the on the phone
staff in that inch X. retain
town.
And for example since and loss
of the local ability. To provide
start up monies for creative
services or just rate for next
level service.
Local area challenges here in
the valley transportation
accessing costs rural areas have
limited resources.
As I said earlier acting
training [inaudible]
Personnel also.
Well in 30% speed occupational
therapy physical therapy.
Hi but pretty and in security
valley.
And safe and adequate housing I
addressed a little bit earlier.
I got a couple more minutes.
I'm almost done --
And also the bridge funding that
was recently up local --
Providers in this area were
preemptively excluded --
I know the decision hasn't been
fully made yet but at the
hearing we were told that we
were being excluded because were
considered a low cost area.
But if you look at the
challenges we face in the valley
and you accommodate for those
factors were probably just as
high cost is up other areas --
ABA services transition to
insurance has been a challenge --
Families are very confused
around enrollment with insurance
which providers are in network.
And the things that we use to
rape working with our providers
within the regional centers pay
their bills on time a lot of our
providers have billing
department now.
And don't get their paid on time
for the insurance companies
staffing crisis I've touched on
a little bit earlier --
Touch trusted staffer leaving
rage compression --
And providers not of the pay
directs this professionals more
than minimum wage so they're
leaving for and number and stuff
ox care take is used.
As a trusted spit opportunities
and not all families could
depress but on a monthly basis
but that one time --
For two weeks was very helpful
for families --
And also reduce unnecessary
administrative burdens I've read
through the latest a hundred and
fifty trailer bill since two
thousand eight line by line and
there's a lot of room I think
they're for change --
Keep DC closure money in the
community based system I know
this is been a hot topic over
the last while we have portable
mental center own backyard.
In her --
All done with our Xin the Jack
treatment closure.
On but many follow a certain
person follow vigils challenging
needs but it would be nice for
to come to this around in the
job find.
Stop at some of these --
Cost thing that.
That would address some of these
issues I brought up earlier.
System solutions fully fine
staffing and other crucial rates
the rate study is an opportunity --
Allow regional is once again to
address crucial rates it tears
up local.
Full funds.
Refresh [inaudible]
And finally.
Collaboration is crucial it's
really imperative to do is
you're doing today listen to
families vigil service covers
provide there's the biggest
champions with someone chair.
Of for the population in the
capital also so [inaudible]
Assemblymember.
I want to start if I can by
apologizing for being late I
have a responsibility as a
parent professional myself and
on days that I'm home I pick up
my three daughters --
And are three five and seven
year old sometimes preoccupied
me at home.
I wanted to be able to come here
and I'm quite pleased that
assemblymember Frazier.
Decided to hold this select
committee hearing here today.
In Fresno.
Because oftentimes our voices in
the Central Valley are not heard
in our state capitol.
Easy where they the Los faces on
the loss of Shauna skin number
the outlined and copy thousand
this stuff.
So on board okay tangle meal.
E. aqui en and bias and problems
the son Joaquin I parts only the
odds but I realize you sub
doubles.
The grass yes but a lot but to
me the I. but it's the idea.
I wanna thank you for the
opportunity to be here.
And I will stop just to allow.
More time for the can this.
We don't hear from our community
and I really look forward to
this opportunity today so thank
you for having this year.
Thank you doctor and I just want
to acknowledge a couple members
of staff have.
Joined us this evening also --
We have in.
Compare with us some member
Patterson's office.
And we have --
Denise of runs.
From assemblymember Rubio's
offices record okay good good to
see you guys and thank you.
And please share with your
members we appreciate.
Your participation in in the
hearing today --
We're gonna move on to our next
panelist Alaska --
Rear mirrors. To come on up to
the to the podium please.
Greetings.
Good evening thank you so much
assemblymember Frazier for
chairing the select committee
first and foremost and also for
having these listening sessions
these hearings.
And thank you so a member of
Arambula for being here tonight
to support us.
I'm it's again like heather said
it's just great to have you here
in Fresno and thank you amber
was in joint meeting with you
and talking --
I think I'll take less time so
we can get caught up quick --
Saw many hit my timer --
So first of all and executive
director twenty eight years I've
been executive director for
twenty of those years and I know
that the lord above has blessed
me with this job and I feel so.
Privileged to work for people
with developmental disabilities
first and foremost.
I'm and I'm here tonight
strictly for them --
To share with you --
Wonderful things that we're
doing in the community as
service providers but many of
the struggles that were having
and so the very first thing that
I I could just say in publicidad
on would be insufficient funding.
If we just stop there and more
money came our way would be very
helpful to address many of our
issues and concerns.
The main thing --
I've been around long enough to
know that the rates been frozen
twenty plus years and is some of
my peers will remember there
were cost statements at the time
the DDS would require from us.
And you centers in every two
years and they were actual
dollars that you spent and then
you've got a rate to meet your
needs to keep doing this service
will that was frozen in nineteen
ninety eight we have had to
increases that were --
Primarily for wage pass through
which is desperately needed to
paid staff her doing this work
hands on so we did have money
I'm about to year goes with the
AB two X. --
One dollars there were one time
in -- Two
thousand four one of the things
that --
Heather brought up is about and
we're thankful there three left
and we agreed that the hundred
plus million dollars that we
believe the state would save --
Every year after the closure
will lead to should go back into
the system that serves the
people that were serving three
earned thirty thousand plus
people in California --
So one of the biggest things
with staffing --
With --
Funding being so tough is that
we are having a much harder time
now attracting qualified staff.
And right now --
On any given day you at our
agency we serve a six hundred
and thirty five adults --
And we do it with two hundred
staff and we usually have
between seven and ten positions
open at any given time.
And to so that causes a real
problem with ratios you're
supposed to required to have so
many staff for pretty clients
you're serving.
And that makes very hard so and
now we're learning because
minimum wage we all agree people
deserve to make more money --
To living out there is getting
tough -- But
the people are now leaving for
jobs that are they concert to be
a much less stressful job I was
at a restaurant recently and I
had the gumption to actually
asked the waitress because she
seems so.
Knowledgeable about her job and
very good which is about me
disabled adults and really since
it's a lot less stress.
Is like wow you know I couldn't
even convince somebody in a
restaurant to maybe consider to
help a human being and services
and so that's a sign of our
times -- So
that's what's probably the
biggest --
Hurdle for many of our providers
I'm only speaking for they are
tonight but for most of the
providers are here --
They experience the same thing
minimum wage going up in 202075%
of our staff will be a minimum
wage and all other wages will
have collapsed we will be almost
on the same all of our fifteen
sixteen your employees or more
will be.
At the same level and so that's
gonna be a huge --
Concern for us --
Because we're gonna lose a lot
of staff they're going to move
on to other jobs --
Were concerned a better quality
of services can be very
challenging we expect outcomes
for individuals there's goals
and objectives that need to be
tracked.
And we're going to be concerned
about the revolving door staff
there's no continuity then in
the service when you deal with
people with disabilities.
And so with constant changing of
staff gives no consistency or
care of support of the people we
serve and that's public the most
concerning to me --
We are always juggling every
single day to you --
Plug the holes in the boat that
feels like the waters just
pouring out everywhere --
It's just gonna get worse the
next couple years it seems kind
of I'm kind of on you know
twenty years I'm kind on the
downhill slide of my career here
and it's just really I'm.
Disheartening to see what's
happening to the system so --
So then on top of this of the
funding -- I
want to stick with that because
and you know unfortunately DDS
we did have I know recession
cuts that we needed to take in
two thousand eight nine and ten
I believe it was.
And but the state has totally
turned around we understand
governor brown has done some
great job and putting like nine
billion dollars in rainy day
funds which is great.
But when in our system when
we're now hit with half day
billing and with more for more
closure days --
That's a hundred sixty thousand
dollars or agency that's not a
little small amount of money to
us -- And so
that's really --
A little overwhelming when you
know the state does have nine
billion dollars and rainy day
funds -- I
and I think people with
development disabilities are
very deserving of every
opportunity life that you and I
are in so.
That we have to go through these --
May through is very I'm
upsetting --
One of the other things to is
when we run these agencies we
are a nonprofit we've been on a
five oh one see --
Three but we were very lean
administration group so it
because it takes people to
manage the people that manage
the direct care staff.
I'm we have the same needs of
corporate --
Businesses and technically I
could use at least four or five
more on lead manager and
director positions to help us
keep doing what we're doing to
keep the doors open to help.
The direct care staff --
But I just recently have two
openings for manager jobs and
three people that applied for
the jobs when we told with the
salary was declined immediately --
And so we don't have a long line
at the door to come in and and
do the jobs in the services that
we want to offer.
And so -- It
just seems like every day
there's just another obstacle
another roadblock to giving good
quality services to people with
disabilities --
Another thing that is happening
is transportation is --
An issue the federal government
expects --
More community Gration with two
thousand twenty two I'm from the
five of our five in the
community we do integrate --
But for us to get more based on
with them CMS rules looking for
we need bunch on many more staff
and vehicles --
And so one of the things that I
want to share with you was that --
I did a quick analysis of those
four five positions and if I put
how many vehicles I need to get
out and I need staff.
And if we were to pay them the
right salaries to do the jobs it
would require 2225% increase and
then of course the bumps up the
different levels as we go up.
My agency alone almost needs to
million dollars more a year to
do everything sufficiently and
meet all those needs.
And so on were just --
Not sure winner if that money
will be coming so I'm the other
thing is that --
The we offer work activity
programs and there's been a lot
of concern about --
How valid those are and if we
should be looking at closing
those and we believe that every
individual deserves an operate
shoot for employment wherever
they see fit that's their choice?
And we want to make sure that
the state does not consider
closing any kind of options that
are out there in that are
available.
And so we want to really
encourage you to talk to others
about employment opportunities
for our clients and making sure
that all options are out there
for them that we don't close
anything.
I'm.
I think the last thing that I
want to say is that --
So we work really hard to meet
the needs of the families in the
individuals we serve and we take
this job so seriously.
And that we want to do more and
better for them --
But right now we are being
stranglehold but also by a lot
of regulatory constraints also
problematic for us it's amazing
the amount of documentation and
audits and reviews and
everything that we go through on
top of it feels like some days
we don't even get to talk.
Or touch the individual we're so
busy meeting regulatory things
and so -- We
can use some real relief and
that -- And
so.
I have many new ideas and things
that we could --
Suggests that could be looked at
and would like to submit that to
both later at another time but
in closing I just would really
implore you.
To think about the funding first
and foremost and go from there
but thank you so much for
tonight and for this opportunity.
So I will tell you that --
Through my office we do hire the
arc in Contra Costa county to do --
I gives certificates of
recognition to every high school
graduate in my districts was
about eighty thousand a year.
And we hire the are to do the
certificates right.
Alphabetized all Ole the quality
is unsurpassed yeah and so you
know I highly recommend anybody
has an opportunity.
To utilize this work forces as
and some amazing opportunity and
and but yeah it kinda you got is
you have to settle up.
All right so.
Thank you for the plug I don't
have to say any of it is good to
hear using --
But yeah that's how we feel
there such as they are hard
workers they're dedicated they
show up there their amazing
individuals and so we want to
give them every chance to work
just like you and I thank you
again.
Work in progress thank you.
So move on to a Teman water
board certified behavioral.
Analyst pleased at the podium
please [inaudible]
See [inaudible]
Thank you.
My name is Tamera one and I am a
Central Valley native.
Go eagles Clovis west graduate --
I began my career is behavior
analysts at hold them back
behavioral health in nineteen
ninety four so I've been there
for some time.
And that has allowed me to see
lots of different trends here in
the valley --
Hold a master's degree in
psychology and a board
certification from the a and B.
A. C. B..
I am.
And the clinical director --
For the early intervention
program for children with autism.
And I also oversee engine
services for individuals with
developmental disabilities other
than autism of all ages --
I also my parent professional
have twelve children.
And and seven of them have
physical disabilities and one is
an adult with intellectual
disabilities so I do understand
that and appreciate the unique
challenge of obtaining.
Services for individuals
especially adults with
developmental disabilities.
An first I just wanted to talk a
little bit about what ABA is ABA
that acronym applied behavior
analysis.
Be here now is this is the
science of behavior which is a
history.
Has a history extending back to
the early twentieth century.
Its underlying philosophy is
behaviorism which is based on
the premise that attempting to
improve the human condition be
he is three behavior change.
I'm basic behavior analytics
scientists have conducted
thousands of studies to identify
the laws of behavior and the
predictable ways in which
behaviors learned and how to
change it over time.
The underlying theme of much
work has been that behavior is a
product of its circumstances
particularly the events that
immediately follow the behavior.
Supplied behavior analysis
analysts have been using the
information to develop numerous
techniques and treatment
approaches for analyzing and
changing behavior and ultimately
to improve lives.
Because this approach is largely
based on behavior and its
consequences the techniques
generally involve teaching
individuals more effective ways
of behaving in making changes to
social consequences of existing
behavior.
AB Aizen Pericles shown to be
effective in a wide variety of
areas including parent training.
Substance abuse treatment
dementia management brain injury
rehabilitation occupational
safety intervention and among
others however because ABA was
first applied to the treatment
of individuals with intellectual
disabilities and autism.
This is the practice that is
most largely evidence based and
has received the most
recognition.
Am I work for holding back
behavioral health we've been a
provider here in the Central
Valley for over thirty years --
We provide individual
assessments and we decide design
individual intervention to
address the specific needs of
families in our community we
help increase behaviors such as
language acquisition cooperation.
Pre academic readiness toilet
training self management other
socially valued behaviors we
also said assist with the
reduction of behavior such as
aggression or self injurious
behavior.
We help people throughout their
lives is needed addressing the
unique challenges faced by
individuals.
Like children teens and adults.
Our early intervention services
for young children with autism.
And when I first started in the
field this is not a service that
was covered.
By the regional centers by
insurance it wasn't recognized
as something that was vital --
And since it is now and funded
through the Central Valley
regional center and now I've
seen that transition to an
health insurance companies and
now medi cal.
Sting quite a ride.
And it since it's services for
children with a diagnosis of
autism focus on core behavior
deficits in accesses parents
participate in one to one
intensive services between an
analyst in a child.
The assessment and intervention
plan are proposed to
specifically address that
individual child's and deficits
in accesses.
It's a huge commitment by
families we're looking at ten to
forty hours a week of service
for a child that might be two
years to four years of age.
And however --
As a conservative taxpayer
myself and a scientist I've
always interest in the data --
So.
Because of the accountability of
that we were curious as the
company to see the fiscal impact
which I think is important to
all y'all.
All y'all's what we say here in
Central Valley.
Home we're very curious about
the fiscal impact and so we did
some in house research looking
at children with the diagnosis
of autism he received early
intervention services.
Defined as twenty hours or
greater beginning before the age
of 485290% of those children
landed in general education
public school.
With no support.
You could not identify them from
other children in a class.
And now I'd like to say that is
because we're create company.
Well it's actually because of
great team thing to do with just
as it --
It's not an accident though it's
result of good AB services with
calf careful treatment planning.
Parents to commit to consistent
services and sacrifice countless
hours for children's progress.
It's result of staff who
diligently followed through with
program curriculum teachers who
collaborated with us it was
result of whites funding from a
regional center careful steps to
achieving accountability for the
provider and the parent and
straight up hard work.
Is result of team work.
And we to as a company
experience a lot of the
challenges that and that the ark
experience it's very difficult
for us.
To an attract and retain
individuals who are.
Trained in in behavior analysis
who might speak Spanish you
might speak mom who are eager to
help in a very stressful job.
We've had rate freezes for very
long time --
But I'm hooked so I'm not going
anywhere because once you seen a
child and progress and you see a
family and turn around to be
able to have dinner together is
here child say their first words.
You get hooked so.
An a couple of then we also work
with.
I do want to leave out that we
also work with teens and adults.
And as it provider I've seen not
population of individuals who
missed out on that early
intervention.
Applied behavior analysis still
works for them it's a different
set of unique challenges --
And so we do provide services to
teens and adults.
And we help increase behavior
such as effective communication
safety awareness self management
and other socially valued
behaviors increase independence
and autonomy.
Also system reduction with
behaviors that create barriers
for them such as aggression or
self injurious behavior
[inaudible]
An here in the valley.
We do have some unique
challenges that I see.
As a provider and families.
We're in fast geographic areas
you'll now.
And since we provide services in
the homes that means we're
having staff drive.
Needs vast geographic areas --
And since autism and other
disabilities they're not
discriminative the impact the
entire community reaching from
every socioeconomic class every
gender every race and ethnicity
and every corner of our
community.
Several unique challenges --
That come to mind as heather
mentioned is reaching the many
variety of cultures and and
families where.
Stereotypically Sam are
skeptical of outsiders coming
and so providing centers or
other --
Means of attaining applied
behavior analysis would be great.
But again it takes spending.
Am keep keeping in retaining and
monolingual Spanish speaking.
Employees has been so difficult.
True story I played a plate I
played to hold them back
behavior health when they were
hiring for a modeling tools are
bilingual Spanish speaking
individual I speak no Spanish
what I thought I could find
people that speaks.
You can find people that speak
other languages but it is a
unique challenge keeping them
retaining them.
On in the in the work force reap
freezes and difficulties with
that [inaudible]
I am.
Another trend that I've seen.
As the health insurance and
Medicare transitioning.
We are so blessed that front
Central Valley regional center
has been incredible with helping
through those transitions I feel
like it's a team teamwork thing.
Every day I work with three
different regional centers and
this is a star regional center
Central Valley regional center
talk about team work and
transitioning.
South are not afraid to hold
providers accountable.
In as a provider I'm thankful
for that because I've seen many
providers.
Senate shop here in the valley
there here today gone tomorrow
in so I think that
accountability continued and is
very important.
For our consumers.
And I heard a time I think I'm
done [inaudible]
Now.
I think I'm done.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
We're gonna move on to Mister
chairman have just absolutely
Christmas --
There's a reoccurring theme and
I wanted to highlighted because
it's nice when we hear it to
make sure that we capture it and
that was transportation --
I was recently at monta Vista
it's a in read Lee and they have
moderate to severe developmental.
Disabilities and they were
discussing similar concerns
about transportation.
And so I just wanted to take a
moment and highlight that if I
could.
And also to say the importance
of early intervention --
Tomorrow I'm going to a
conference in.
Adverse childhood experiences
which for those of you that have
not heard me before it's what I
believe is the single largest
public health discrepancy that
we're not talking about enough.
And so I hope that those of you
in the room will take this
opportunity to do some research
on it.
There's a wonderful book called
the deepest well if you have not
read it it's one of the best
books I've read in a decade.
Based off what you are saying I
think you also see the
importance of that early
intervention and that it is wise
for us to make sure we are.
Funding it appropriately.
Our fellow thank you a doctor
Arambula who as I mentioned he
has been such a champion in the
assembly and we talk about so
many issues that we've --
Motorcross and then shared the
committee shared with us and we
both fought.
Tirelessly home.
But to no avail sometimes things
get up to the administration and
and they're not supported and so --
We have a new a new a regime
coming in.
And hopefully a new.
Opportunity cool going forward.
When you talk about the
transportation and?
And the chairman of
transportation in the assembly
in California and we have a
funding bill that sound after
the election.
Dr their seven hundred million
dollars a year in public transit
will look at utilizing for this
population it.
And trying to make sure that the
Central Valley is identified
because of the role nature and
and making sure that the your
clients and your consumers are
absolutely --
Cared for so that's one thing
that I will commit myself to on
that [inaudible]
Are you.
So anyway we're gonna move on
and again thank you for your
testimony.
A removal into a are a self
advocate Caroline --
Approaches to tailor a billion
[inaudible]
Hello in.
Please step [inaudible]
For close.
Who was pretty close --
So I'm gonna talk fast.
Catcher.
But I want to thank you both for
having us here.
And for having all of this here
this is a great team we all work
together for many years I want
to say --
When I'm a heroes as Dr Phil and?
Studies I use in my work as a
social worker licensed clinical
social worker valley children's.
And and I'm basically I'm here
because I'm a parent to what I
want to do is put a face on
these issues that have been
spoken about.
So when we talk about
transportation I want you to
visualize what that means and
when we talk about.
Things like --
Recreation what that actually
means to the person because we
haven't had too much of a clear
picture on that yeah.
So -- She
has ever asked me to give you a
little bit of my involvement so
you know that I'm.
A credible credible witness --
I collaborated with my cell
unified to start the first
includes a preschool program if
I sell yeah.
My daughter was a for students
to be fully included. Twenty
five years ago Tulare county
school.
It's a parenting resource center
that's and buy sell you a
similar to the one and if you.
Aye road received a two point
five million dollar federal
grant to start us tips of
program here in Fresno.
Which is way finders at Fresno
state for people with
intellectual disabilities.
Birth seedier see an S. C. DD's
self determination advisory
committee for the past three to
four years.
Founded and facilitated a parent
support group for the down
syndrome association the Fresno
I participate in the war on the
walk on Washington.
With a doubt national down
syndrome society to advocate to
say Medicaid --
And down syndrome research and
other medical initiatives that
relate to our people with down
syndrome other ID and all say ID
to keep it quick short.
I. volunteers a private
consultant and advocate for
parents at their child's eyed
peas for those of autism and
down syndrome and the Central
Valley I've also been asked to
be an expert witness for special
education attorney here in town.
And a valley children's hospital
I work with children.
With idea who are medically
fragile and sometimes I work
with parents who have ID and our
regional center clients that
also have children.
With the ID and her medically
fragile.
So my biggest thing is we've
heard already competitive wage
wages for caregivers.
The high turnover rate for
carriers who leave for higher
paying jobs.
With almost any job being a
higher rate.
This for my daughter lives in a
house with her two friends and
staff of my daughter's home
results a lack of continuity and
security fell by the girls in
their own home.
Care givers usually work part
time so that benefits don't have
to be paid by the employer
because of their constraints.
And the move on for higher wages
health insurance and other
benefits many work more than one
job to make ends meet.
There's a lack of qualified
workers also because of these
low wages and they I have that
and none of them have many have
come to work in the girls home
that have had no experience
working with a person with a
disability.
The pay support staff that I've
worked with my daughter includes
these agencies respite in home
supportive services independent
living services supported living
services.
And a day program [inaudible]
Housing.
Housing let me give you the
picture there's a lack of a poor
formal housing and safe
neighborhoods.
Choices are limited my daughter
in her to remove roommates with
down syndrome are able to afford
to rent and this.
The same neighborhood that I
live in only due to them sharing
the reasonable and reduced rate.
Given by the landlord and having
three of them live together in
the same house so they can share
expensive.
This would not be feasible ishe
if my daughter wanted to live by
herself or with one other person
or in another city. For contacts
they pay twelve hundred dollars
a month and you heard rented a
small apartment so thousand so
it is a really rose reasonable
rate.
And that she received about.
A thousand dollars a month for
social security.
In my job and help the couple
from Kern county regional center
who were the parents were --
Clients moved to be closer to
our hospital at valley
children's.
Because they had a daughter who
had ID and developmental
disabilities and was medically
fragile we could only find a
section eight housing apartment
for them.
In in that part of town which we
lay.
Criminal activity and gangs the
soon had to leave.
Transportation another favorite.
And I'll give you a picture of
that as they will go through
this for those with ID the handy
right system has had ongoing
problems.
And with being unreliable and
untimely also are handy right
can't cross country county lines.
So if you want to come from
Clovis to valley children's
hospital you cannot take the
saying --
Handy right you have to switch
county county.
Resources.
Basically there's no real
transportation available those
two with ID that have factors
that put their safety at risk.
Regional center under SLS us
that the girls learn to take the
city bus which I understand.
But while I'm sure that they can
learn to maneuver the bus system
to a certain extent.
The fact remains that three
young ladies who are five feet
tall and under.
Who don't look typical are going
to be targeted by others who are
waiting to take advantage of
them?
Safety is a key issue for all of
us.
And on and Salas program to
fight transportation I would
like to see an independent
company established that will
cry transportation services.
That's a standalone of like them
see vendor through the regional
center.
Bet that with or without self
determination that research
there that resource can be
accessed through our regional
center.
I know of two young men recently
who took the city bus. One with
autism and one with a AT.
Who were bullied another young
man with autism who was lost on
the bus system because he didn't
know where to get off?
And his phone had died he was
found hours later.
I would like to speak a little
bit about Central Valley
regional center I have a long
relationship with them.
And a very good when.
I think that the regional center
budget not billing fully
refunded has resulted in changes
in processes and policies that
have medical negatively affect
our community which you've heard.
The first of the loss of social
recreation cam funding which is
made a huge impact on my
daughter's life and her peers.
Again let me put a face on this.
My daughter has to dance classes
in dances for two and a half
hours a week well you might say
well that's an extra not
everybody can do that.
Let me explain the benefits of
dance with this extra curricular
activity and house of impacted
her life.
Dance is provided building
friendships and socialization
with her typical peers and non
typical peers.
Movement exercise building tone
in maintenance.
Promoting her physical and
mental strength and this is an
actively seeking help for the
rest of her life this is
something we all want to have.
Another is a change in the
behavioral services is being
offered by.
By -- To
bother to Perrance.
Well my child was in grade
school age I was able to call
regional center get behaviors
within a couple weeks to come to
my house. To help with.
The beef behavior this is before
the cats.
This is no longer helping
parents are now required to take
it behavior modification class
parenting class the feedback I
have received that the parents
are first really hesitant to go
been find it very valuable.
However when there's a behavior
that's disrupting the whole
house.
The whole home family home in
these to be a quicker way to get
a behaviorist of this at the
family before stresses hiring.
And the family unit is there and
I see this as a social worker
and as a parent.
About twenty years ago the
regional center implemented a
great plan to get a dozen
parents. To be trained.
By a behavior management agency
that was from Sacramento
instructor taught about six of
those couples over an eight to
ten week period of time I can't
remember exactly.
And we were given the tools
together in.
Tools -- To
test and implement a behavior
plan for a child this was done
with videos group work in
instruction Burke but an essence
we became behavior modification
Saudi.
And I won't no longer called the
reason center for behaviors help.
I could do that on my own.
Education which is my last area.
Here a few of the most pressing
issues with comment threads a
see happening across the state I
have my own experiences with bad.
And her from other families in
person and through other state
advocacy groups that I belong.
To the individuals with
disabilities act IDA.
That was an act in nineteen
ninety is being ignored.
Parents are still fighting for
full inclusion I've fought for
this twenty five years ago and
they're still having.
The same ridiculous fight.
District state and there's
several districts I have worked
with.
That they don't do full
inclusion they don't give one on
one support.
Maybe give you a few hours are
part of the day the status are
policy and the policy differs
from federal.
Laws there's the that support
the request for an inclusive
setting and ideas least
restrictive environment.
We don't have the resources is
not in the best interests of
your child these are things I
have heard why do you keep doing
this to your child she was
starting first grade.
Arm.
So what that's not what the
parents are asking.
For what they wanted their child
to learn alongside their their
age appropriate peers it's about
learning the same material.
Adapted to their needs and with
necessary accommodations as
required by law however even
with going to fair hearing many
parents lose the battle.
Another problem is that most
schools and teachers don't
ascribe to follow us of the of
assume competence.
As soon confidence in our kids.
They don't challenge arches his
with age appropriate educational
opportunities instead of her
juvenile activities.
I can tell you act ideas about
that later.
I met teachers who have taught
for twenty years or more and
have no training and I'm almost
done.
In teaching children with ID
they're never taught even one
child with the ID and a local
school that didn't have one
child with ID in their whole
school.
Or district they have only had
kids with physical disabilities
the teacher told once told me.
Who's going to teach that child
when she found out a child with
down syndrome is coming into her
kindergarten class.
This just happened a couple
years ago.
It's important to note that
students with ID are graduating
with high school diplomas and
taking college courses and
getting real jobs.
The good things we have in
Fresno here's my ending.
We do have I feel one of the
best regional centers and I see
that from all the communications
I have throughout the state.
They have worked well with me I
feel I've been reasonable with
them and they have been
reasonable with me.
We have the down Sonora
socialization of central
California break the barriers
exceptional Perrance unlimited
post secondary education program.
Projects search brought by my
good friend Michelle Smith.
Part of the horse the ark Fresno.
Participate our kids participate
in and a day program that even
focuses just on art.
Something my daughter also
laughs. One thing I would like
to see come --
To Fresno is the Joey Travolta
film camp in workshops come to
the valley there in Livermore
and they just started one in
Stockton.
Undertaking names right now and
I know someone who's traveled
the country working and being
paid by them and she has on the
intellectual disability.
I thank you for your time
respectfully [inaudible]
Thank you.
Thank you for that so we'll move
on to work our next battle she
won a cruise.
Thank you for being here this
evening.
Thank you for allowing us to
come here and talk about what's
going on the Central Valley I'm
along the crew some with the
state council on developmental
disabilities.
This acquire region --
We cover seven counties.
From Mariposa all the way down --
To current.
So a little bit about me I
actually came.
To the Central Valley about
three years ago.
Have been working for the State
Council.
For a long time.
But I was actually working for
the state council in Orange
County.
So I've seen.
The difference between what
happens in Orange County and
what happens in the Central
Valley.
And I'm gonna I'm gonna agree
with you as far as working with
the regional center.
I've seen different regional
centers county have several --
Orange County has one and it's
not always as easy as it has
been here so I do want to
commend the regional center and
I do also want to commend.
All the agencies that have.
Allowed me to to work with them
because it has been.
A very.
Different experience working in
the Central Valley arm the one
thing I do want.
To point out is the
transportation I know we keep
talking about transportation.
But coming from.
Los Angeles the Long Beach area
I'd it never dawned on me how.
Big the area who is here how
long it would take me to get
from.
Fresno to Mendota didn't realize
that there wasn't more than.
Two lanes basically getting
there so.
If I struggle with my car trying
to get to certain places I can
only imagine what it's like to
have to rely on public
transportation.
So a little bit about what we do
our objectives is a State
Council as we are we have.
Twelve regional offices and
again mind the Senate bill Dolly.
On this the county was is pushed
the temporal lobe as it
independence day eight C. we are
leading please what does little.
To our we have the LCD is made
up of thirty one people
appointed by the governor.
And what we do so we support
systems advocacy I'll talk a
little bit at what looks.
We do a lot training.
In the past used to be an H. B.
that lottery and David Blatt see
me in would go on to keep peace
we would talk to we went. To for
adults who needed transition
program.
Are we change to the way we do
things and there's been some you
know there's really some.
The downside about changing that
is that we don't really get to
inner act with families as much
as we used.
To but we do get to fit get to
find out what the what systems
are working and what systems are
having on issues.
So we do look at innovative ways
to to help --
Other agencies to try to come up
with solutions.
We offer resources and we have a
wonderful state plan that we are
look at to figure out what we
need to do --
As a whole in the state or in my
little area of the Central
Valley [inaudible]
He so again we provide a lot of
training I do believe that
educating our community.
Is the way we are going to be
able to get understand what's
this is our avail.
It's not John.
Admit you know the point is if
you know what's this is our
global not into what to ask.
For some time.
It can be the difference.
Are yours X. sometimes families
don't know how to describe
what's going on which makes it
difficult for agencies to figure
out what type of services --
That family might need --
Let's see.
We do that again we do the
systemic advocacy I'll talk a
little bit about that.
We work with the different
communities different providers
here that I've worked with --
And we had our this we do have
the cell to self determine the
state wide self determination
advisory committee.
So some of the gold all the
goals that we address our self
advocacy.
We address formal and more
community supports that things
like home port of service.
It's one agent that we have
really talked about but in.
That required.
Twenty four seven odd type
support.
I'll see a new house is huge we
know the house.
Issue all California we know
that certain areas you just
can't afford to live in --
We do have that same issue here
I think here. One of the biggest
challenges is getting and with
those developers letting them
know that our population also
needs housing that they need to
set aside units that could house
our population.
Early intervention education
transition and post secondary
education you brought up
education and I'm gonna talk a
little bit about.
What that is like one of the
biggest issues here several
school districts just?
Do not believe in inclusion and
inclusion you know we talk about
being an inclusive society but
if we can't even get a school
district to agreed. To place in
a child in an inclusive
environment being in a regular
class with.
With other other children not
just being in a special day
class as an option you know that.
That really kind of conflicts
our whole inclusive environment --
A philosophy.
And we do do we do a lot with
health and safety.
See we also ward community
grants so.
Just so you all know keep an eye
on it I keep an eye out for our
community ground.
Level.
On our part of the year sets and
disability rights.
Our other one are funny voices
minutes Xin for could community
living.
So what I'm doing --
I think one of the big things
that the special that is doing
right is all into other.
We are all.
In the nation do you think Bob
[inaudible]
Can someone.
We talk about it and it is what
happens most of the time.
Will get call.
We'll get several calls about
the image.
After file because looking at
houses stem vacancy.
We look at it we we were is that
there is a trend and at that
point we might.
You know talk to a director of
an agency let them know this is
what's going on how can we help
you so that.
We don't continue having to hear
about these gonna these issues
that are going on so I think
that the Central Valley has that.
We have that going for us were
able to communicate were able to
use each other --
I know one of the things that I
want to talk about his
disparities solutions like. For
example room heather talked
about her Brough her promoted a
project.
That's a big deal.
In.
And I'll tell you what you think
it's going to be effective
because they were kind enough to
have me come in.
And train their promote thought
us on generic resources.
You know generic resources is a
it's an important part of
services to people with
developmental disabilities.
It's not just.
Bad -- That
they're receiving services from
Central Valley regional center
or from the school district.
The generic resources our HSS
art SSI.
Are -- Medi
cal all those other services
that that a person might require
in order to be able to live in
an inclusive environment.
Inclusive society.
Are let's see the sequoia office
which is I'm a my office has.
Provided IEP trading's not only.
To to the Central Valley
regional center staff.
There are service coordinators.
So that they can go out and help
advocate for their clients.
Let's see we've also provided
trainees for Madera county
mental health their therapists
because they've stay actually
identified a trend.
With one of the dais with one of
the does in Madera county
regarding even.
The child SS so there's trends
here that are happening.
And and we're helping with
advocating for not only one
child but just the community and
in the whole.
Are working together on projects
like to me tomorrow we're having
a huge self advocacy conference
would've been so nice for you to
be here.
We're having a huge self
advocacy conference in all of us
have worked together to get this
going is gonna be at least two
hundred and fifty self advocates
their learning about the safety
piece to get safe --
And also learning about how to
advocate for themselves.
I do want to talk about the
systems advocacy peace that we
worked on so educational for
example.
We talked the talk include.
Include and I we were.
Is -- But
there's a local district that it.
Well the for next to do with it
Bassman the oldest just clean
assessments for Chau.
So.
In have.
Command has identified my done.
I'm are will be to receive.
A and has been has done a that
he you know there's something
going on with my child.
In this listing instead of you
know it shouldn't have to get to
this point.
I definitely don't want to have
to follow state complaint but if
that happens you know it's gonna
be because we just and come to a
solution when I'm getting ten
calls for the same issue.
I have to do something about it.
The other piece the inclusion
piece we have a district that
refuses to include children.
And one of our cases that we
identified as the systemic
issues getting ready to go to
the ninth circuit.
Hey that's going to be December
twentieth and it's really.
Fun inclusion the law has always
said let's include and we're
still what this case has to go
to the ninth circuit parents are
spending an enormous amount of
money.
Just to get this case hard.
And transportation that's the
whole issue but we can talk
about that solid --
Just a little bit about us and
that's just that's me in
[inaudible]
Okay.
And I didn't want [inaudible]
Introduce our mind newest rack
member my regional advisory
committee member Michael ask of
all who is also a self advocate.
And who was gonna talk about.
How you doing Sir?
I bet you I bet you don't know
what I'm gonna talk to you about
[inaudible]
Transportation [inaudible]
He well let me just give a brief
about me --
My name is Michael is given I
was born in the California --
At a very young age I was
diagnosed restore opposing from
birth.
And it was --
Heartfelt for me to go through
it as through the years --
Who was the it all year round in
Exeter --
But I wanted to make a
difference.
And I went to college the
cigarettes for two years of
fortunate in go my way there.
But I still wanted to make it I
wanted to be an advocate loading
behold I worked for able
industries.
For the I don't know if you're
familiar with able industries
it's their invoice LA California
they work with --
Developmental disabled.
And they they have a shop inside
where where the severe they they
were they do --
Piece work you could say they do
for the police --
The jail they make the the
packets.
I was one of the fortune wants
to claim the parks in by so yeah.
And that was in a good thing
because it.
It it and help me.
With the disabled get to know
them get.
To no gets another issues that
they had and their main issue
was transportation.
And that was.
In it it was hard for me because
going through the process I guy
I keep telling you gotta be
patients.
Got to be patient a lot of times
and have patience.
You know you got it you got it
you got to you got to have you
got you just bear with me.
In the unfortunately they're
still around me but the issue
still stands.
There's a lot of people that we
just can't example myself I was
offered a job in point of bill.
Seventeen dollars an hour at the
mental health --
State the hospital janitorial.
Guess what happened. One a aye
aye the jobless therefore we're
ready for me and a friend of my
rainy.
Transportation issue.
The dress are the vendors did
not want to transport from by
Sally up all the way to prevail.
Because they never the right.
Ninety and that was
understandable so unfortunately
I lost that job.
And that that was very that.
A lot.
In.
That I had to make a difference.
With the transportation issue
for seven years I've been trying
to push this fan to make a
difference for the vendors so I
can go to for it to go to
Sacramento.
Senate work Sacramento --
Friends.
The wherever Washington remember.
In the the then and now not
there right now.
And that's a big issue and I'm
I'm hoping I'm I'm having
fifteen you Mister Fisher you
can take care of this.
You know I've I've I've I've
sent emails tomb June.
Kong other congressmen Congress
Kanye.
Congressman.
As either.
Response back.
Not a room [inaudible]
I there are little bit.
Sent on ten a big shot
[inaudible]
Governor brown can you believe
that.
I'll.
Be said Mister brown.
Well the first to call me back
laughing hysterically.
And he said that the the
pressure.
I am proud and I was going.
To do something about it.
I haven't heard anything about
it [inaudible]
Nothing more.
Mister Fisher I'm.
Can take care of this issue. For
other people like myself.
They don't have the the
functions that I have.
Right no I got my my beautiful
rather.
Transport this and this and this
and that.
Is given a free.
At the bell you know
[inaudible]
Yeah.
Yeah that's that's that's the
best I can do right now.
Well thank you for your time in
a really appreciate you Hey I
had a good.
With hard to follow you Michael
but if.
If I can both you and you alone
though are very good advocates
yes we are.
A perfect we work together well
and a lot of situations --
I wanted to highlight a couple
things and then ask for some let
me just say that they don't you
may say or you can take
transportation as far as the bus
system.
But I that's fine but the thing
that I'm dial a ride.
Just so I can.
And or whatever it's called here.
But I gotta get. To I got a good
time work at eight o'clock.
That's hard.
To and I and I think and a very
long.
Time I got to be patient.
I don't know how long I can high
I can learn and back. One of the
hopes I was trying to extend to
you with that --
There are multiple avenues and
people to reach out.
To and that I wanted to avail
ourselves and our off when it's
issues that are concerning us.
Specifically --
I practiced in Selma which is
just south of here and I know
how hard it was for people to
get into town.
Even to get in to Fresno on to
one of the things my office is.
Does is we go out to the
community.
Just on the eleventh we were out
and Carmen on the twenty fifth
we're going out to Selma on
November first were going to be
in cal what park in and November
third were going to be a maxi --
Parks's park the point I'm
trying to see is if there's
opportunities to collaborate
with you Yolanda and I was.
I was going to mention that but
I ran out of time I was at the
which I thought was amazing well
and it is a good opportunity for
us to hear from real advocates
and those who are on the front
lines.
Who are expressing the problems
that you're bring and before us
today Michael and if I can one
more thing please because you
talked about programs and?
Oftentimes get an opportunity to
educate about what we're doing
currently yeah but we made a
change to SSI this year that.
I am aware that you know people
may not be as aware of which is
about cashing out and that.
Previously you could not be on
food stamps and SS I SS P. at
the same time.
That has changed.
The state a California's working
through how we implemented but
it is exciting to think that we
are able to address some of the
food and security.
Also many within our community
struggle with and so there.
Are some things we can points to
that are helpful and wanted to
just highlight those two things.
Thank you sure have a good day.
So order move on to our our
disability rights California --
Mayor Cruz Magdaleno.
Thank you for being here this
evening.
Good evening thank you for the
opportunity to be heard in tight
le allow us to talk --
To to you guys and to our
community about our agency.
Are a little bit about myself
I'm a new immigrant to the
Central Valley.
And I've been blessed with the
opportunity to work for
disability rights California for
approximately eight years now --
More specific to developmental
disabilities I am the former AC
are assisting plane right side
to get for the office of clients
Reyes advocacy.
So I am -- I
a very familiar whereas --
A lot of the issues that had
been presented here today.
I movies of who is this ability
rights California so we are the
agency mandated under federal
law to provide protection and
advocacy.
For individuals with
disabilities I will be here in
Fresno are very fortunate to
have the local office --
It is.
It is relatively small we have
about seven people there --
We have advocates we have out
reach people.
An intake people.
We also house the office of
clients Reyes advocacy hallways
the agency.
Funded by the department of
developmental services to
provide advocacy is specific to
people with developmental
disabilities N. I'm there we
have in this is a clients right
advocate in assisting clients
rights advocate who is here with
us today Jose.
Mendoza of the office of clients
Reyes side because it not only
works -- A
specific to issues related with --
Regional center we provide a lot
of advocacy.
In relation to generic resources
like in home supported service
says -- Also --
We provide advocacy in areas
like special.
Basically any legal issues.
That are pertaining to people
with disabilities we are able to
provide advocacy and needs.
Not able to get directly
involved to provide appropriate --
Referrals for that there are
some areas of the lot when which
we do not practice which is --
Personal injury of family law
those are areas that we would
provide referrals. For that we
also provide training for
parents and clients.
Are in again --
Areas like special education --
In home supported services
social security.
I was asked --
To speak about some of the
issues that we commonly see
coming into our office and and I
think I am not gonna.
Do fair with anything that has
been said here today
transportation it's one of the
big ones.
Are we also get issues related
to regional center eligibility.
And lack of to lack of this
thing which is.
We also hear a lot about.
Our services or parents having
difficulties identifying the
services available through the
regional centered.
I and I think this is more
specific to monolingual Spanish
speaking families.
Are in another issue that we are
seeing it's the community
placement community --
Please ma'am for individuals
with challenging behaviors and
and I have to say that our
regional center has been great
and they have put a lot of
efforts into --
The development of new community
care homes for individuals that
are coming out of there --
I did the disease and we just
hope that that momentum would
continue and we would --
Container about women as
appropriate community placements
for individuals who are already
in the community.
So -- Again
thank you for the opportunity to
be here and to talk about our
agency out we had a hand out
talks about.
The R. C.'s recommendation of
for the safety net of
individuals with disability for
anybody will like --
To to get a copy Jose has them
for us.
Thank you again.
Thank you with that. One two
public comment after doctor limb
I have.
Arambula some comments --
You'd mentioned housing the need
of housing.
How many of?
Of your consumers are at risk or
without housing at this point in
time now.
That's a good mathematical
question.
I know that --
We could run those numbers for
you and get those sent out to
you.
I know I was just talking to the
regional center North Bay about.
I don't Santa Rosa and they were
talking about they had forty
five consumers and we're
homeless at this point in time
and several others that were at
risk so it will be health yeah
we have quite a number of
individuals who reside on the
street as well.
And that we would very much like
to get the appropriate housing
and also they tend to have
comorbid conditions with mental
illness.
In that the other one was just
on ongoing training for your for
your employees and and as a
providers of mention we know
that everybody in this.
This community is as far as
providers and the regional
centers as a a pretty good
turnover of employees.
And what is your training into a
full to make sure that the
people are up to current
standards --
In our doing appropriate of
service to the consumer.
With regard to training for our
staff -- So
when you begin at the central
regional center you have a two
week minimum --
Period where we do orientation
and before we set you free we
also set you up with a mentor.
Of mentors someone who's worked
in the field for quite a long
time and supports you in the
field along with your on going
team there's ongoing training
through the orientation period
for several weeks where they
come back.
For but you really can't do
understand till you've done them --
Such as billion for Medicaid --
Some of our computer systems --
Appeals an advocacy those sorts
of things on going training we
just --
Surveyed our staff for
priorities for training and we
have monthly training at a
minimum that's offered to our
service coordinators for
everything from.
Health issues --
Such as the importance of shall
I said.
Making sure that Bosnia properly --
I know that's not an appropriate
topic on one hand but on the
other hand it is imperative to
people's health and out at risk
of high death if we don't manage
that properly.
And we also work on many other
concepts --
Not just medically related but
also related to advocacy we
doing adolescence of your
mindset the State Council comes
into strains for us.
On I EPS another collaborative
trainings we also have annual
training surround mandated
reporting and those sorts of
things.
So just one other question so I
know there's it a differential
and adult service coordinators
and and the the motor service
corners what is the average.
Senses that you're coordinators
in adult and minor actually
service.
Right now were at one to sixty
eight which is --
Lower compared to our peers in
the state --
But those numbers are rising.
Overtime.
Thank you doctor and questions
taking and public comment I
wanted people to know to relax a
little bit. To know that we're
here to listen to you as your
public servants.
I'm glad we're in my backyard.
And so please take the time that
you need to tell your story --
It's a wonderful opportunity for
us to hear from you and I just
look forward to the public
comment.
Do for public comment is all I
ask you to stand.
In line in the aisle and we're
gonna give you.
Approximate two minutes to try
to to give us your your your
mission will also as I mentioned
will have time afterwards what I
will tell you in this advocacy
that you're doing.
Had a mother who came to one of
my coffees.
And told me about her son had
dyslexia and our schools not
actually servicing that child.
I introduced legislation.
And now schools in California.
Half.
To start that process with
dyslexia so your being here
today.
Can make a difference in not
only your child in this state so
thank you for being here.
If two minutes please take your
name and where you live.
Okay when I started this number
so failure charm mama the holy
are not shown in your space yeah.
Bingo Thurmond doctor.
Is stable as some of the
analysts all glass of poorest
aboard to me that.
A locate your non muscular the
suit [inaudible]
Gala.
Good evening my name is a
Ophelia what's.
I come from Mendoza I have a son --
Also who's here right now
[inaudible]
To I thank.
We'll give was I mucho necessity
the other than that is a lot of
me.
He your is stay in ninety
underling Glaspie possum Louis
your locusts opossum.
Certain English because
everything happens very quickly
silent in the arm.
Of on this side a lot it'll
nominals I only understood what
where do you show the numbers.
Yes and then the campground là
simple isn't that made me you on
is that the letters get the
innocent on a hill none I
understood that this two hundred
and sixty million dollars that
this is the that regional center
has.
ESA the never know say launder
so there's three we duplicate
enough I mean that's Kamala me
up on any of this.
Says he does.
Not have the low.
And I don't know how the money
is being distributed because we
have a lot of needs with Montel
locus insult I feel not in.
The in the by that Los Angeles
bonus of five media my name is I
could be considered for and to
me that I'm informing them of
like what kind of services the
regional centers an assistant da
más die yet is them for my
field glasses.
When he more workshops for to
know what what's available?
And I says --
My clothes.
Thanks to many groups.
And I says --
If a warrant not limping now
thank you forty be you are
burning pinon guess almost guest
already done assist.
We did the advertising the flyer
we did ask anybody needs
services we would be able to
provide them so just let you
know --
Please take your name and where
you're from hi my name is robin
là and I live in Fresno
California --
I want to tell you about my past.
And I'm am doing from unique
family home.
When I moved in with a living
arrangements home unique family
told them that I used to smoke
and drink?
That I've was a run away person
I had to get used to my new
family I become part of the
family will fax.
I came long ways I was a smoker
drinker fighting.
Talking back lying and stealing.
To I was putting my life in
danger.
I was hired.
To ours hard but I got help a
lot.
A living room ramen and Nikki
from unique family helped me
unique family connected me to
our the behavior is.
Yes from ABC's.
He helped me change some bad
behaviors and overcame some
stuff back in the pass that I
went.
To I stay with a livia Rainman
going to five years now.
I have a beautiful daughter
named getting out that change me
more.
My family in unique family
helped me teach my daughter
smart and safe choices.
I lost the second daughter de um
a Libya that.
It was hard to lose her.
Hair was a lot of pain in my
heart and my family helped me
deal with my loss.
I am happy I'm staying with a
living in Raymond still because
if I wasn't living with them I
would be doing the same old
thing that pass.
I just want to say thank you a
Libyan ramen and unique family
for helping and changing me.
And the beautiful smart young
woman I am today thank you by
our it is tell you that my
daughter over here that talking
in the back.
She goes to each year and she
has a disability and I do too
she has --
Speech at lake.
And some added disabilities I
can't say.
And I did.
Please state your name and where
you're from.
I am Lisa Peterson.
And I'm from community
locational services.
And I'm person of self advocacy.
And the things we do not
committee vocational services is
we volunteer.
Our on at an arm of life it
means something to me because it
touches my heart.
In many ways because I how to
love one passed away from cancer.
And on a minute yeah
[inaudible]
Ends.
Become means arm of members of
oxy assault me to use my voice
in ways I can imagine.
So it teaches me to reach out to
others and has additional
responsibility.
So teaches me more than just
every teacher all the levels I
need to learn [inaudible]
It.
Is a huge responsibility.
Arm in the the thing alter like
about me vocational services is
a fitness because water people
nowadays are like over weight
people.
Got made fun of which is really
sad.
And so.
So I have this really awesome
job coach that pushes me to be a
hard to see be the best I can be.
And and the really influences
mean a lot of ways.
And they also have I can be real
casual services have classes
like I'm Spanish and other
classes I can't remember but in.
The also has job skills like a
lot of cleaning like janitorial
stuff.
And stuff like that.
And it also.
Does not observe friendship.
But only not only dot CMU is has
taught me that is more than just
friendship brown family one
joint family [inaudible]
You.
Your name or your from
[inaudible]
Hi [inaudible]
The the like Valley skills like
the are. To a total on shop.
Laundry or tax [inaudible]
What the?
All.
Right shop in [inaudible]
Art [inaudible]
Last [inaudible]
The talents or all [inaudible]
Room [inaudible]
To the the this.
Who is Traci [inaudible]
What do [inaudible]
He you got me [inaudible]
Okay.
So what.
The several.
But what about all [inaudible]
Server [inaudible]
Caught.
I would like.
To hear where you're going with
[inaudible]
Okay.
They could choose is.
I'll get all --
S..
Cara Bronx [inaudible]
The tough time.
All. For like [inaudible]
Harris [inaudible]
Dahle several [inaudible]
The all.
So you know we have to do we
have a lot of people behind you.
And we have very little time
left so what we'll do is you and
I and and doctor Arambula after
this will go ahead and finish up
[inaudible]
Thank you.
Next bigger please.
Please take your name and where
you're from hi my name is Mandos
sorts are in.
Our same V. S. program.
I and I'm really sorry for him --
So we just wanted to say thank
you for this opportunity --
When Amanda was born she was one
would reverse effect that
affected her brain development?
And when when she was born they
all said she wouldn't survive or
a said she wouldn't mark she
wouldn't talk.
And because of these people.
People like this.
She walks into talks cincy does
all kinds of things that
surprises me on a daily basis
[inaudible]
And I'm her biggest sound.
There are services that we can't
we can't get.
That other people can get
because of the funding on and
let me just give you an example
we lived in Arkansas she when we
women's harkens home she's three
and we came back when she was.
Thirteen I thought there's going
to be the same services here.
Pattern Arkansas I was sadly
mistaken.
She has so many more services.
In Arkansas which is a much poor
state Sen California's.
And we came here and are so her
services diminish a man slowly.
Because the funding isn't here
well how come it's there in
Arkansas.
How come it would help him she
had therapy three and four times
a week in here she had it once a
year?
I mean you explain that to me --
So my point is is that if they
can do that in other states why
are we not doing here.
I understand that there's more
people per capita but these
people work hard I mean and I
see I've seen our we've been to
several programs.
Where a really good program
right now but they need funding
they need we need better people
to take care of our kids?
I'm so I'm leaving my daughter
with people that.
I'm not.
A three you have anything else
to say.
No again thank you [inaudible]
Thank [inaudible]
You.
Next.
Can name and where you're from.
Welcome high --
My name is service one and a
work for this company called.
Made of occasional services.
So a little bit about myself
high got there is about two
years ago --
So I was given the opportunity.
To work for them and also work
on my personal goals.
As an individual and find ways
to grow and accomplish my goal
was the best potential I can.
So now I've been working there
for almost two years.
And I'm in and I work as a
receptionist for a birthday
program for a community
professional services.
Sir thanks term about a
paternity against many.
A opportunity to meet new people
to Tom of our program and
services and also how.
Other clients that control
program to learn how. To tell
him how to how to teach them how
to properly advocate for
themselves because if I could do
it anybody else to do it.
And I just wanna thing --
You know my boss for allowing me
to have this topic tricks.
And this amazing opportunity
that is to also be here.
I was wrong.
And I have learned a lot. Three
this program because to be
honest.
I was never.
A person that dot okay I'm gonna
check this out.
This program out so something
tell me.
Check it out some non.
Thanks for to maintain it out I
do have.
A job through this program
server from thankful flora are
those.
Opportunities and that you know
are these people have given me
and thank you for having me here
[inaudible]
Next please.
Veteran eman where from.
Hi I'm generation may.
And I in this.
And I'm it.
Program for ever.
This program.
This program a Mister nay.
On our lives [inaudible]
Why alliance?
I'm learn how wide checks.
And Bonta Brough us and all.
The daily people.
And the room.
Do debts [inaudible]
And the have gifts.
It at the of gives in the arts.
What what I say that?
I would for big brothers no
power could you program.
And I'm a coach over there.
And I coach but as you needs.
There's very.
And I close them how Tegra no.
And I and I I'm a junior died
belt over there.
And among those to have a team
over there.
And the driver team Rudy.
Traveling a homeowner.
And I know [inaudible]
If you.
And alliance and honor from.
Everybody else and as double up.
And I was a kid.
And I want to John Mayer.
I was.
I was -- Can
enjoy mere.
Hours are or in right kid in the
school.
But I learned from them.
I would have. To and to replace
ports. To to play soccer based
baseball basketball swimming and
skiing.
And I'm not from that it's and I
learned how.
And I was in ag sure she and and
that I was awesome.
And I when.
I was.
I was that --
Hi manager current agreement
common manager.
Photophobia financially.
And I was I wasn't too and thank
you.
For our company and please fix
avails and and first of a fix.
Our this is so much.
I don't like them they took on
my friends rare [inaudible]
As tomorrow CNN.
Availability.
To and I got pic on making fun
of me.
Every time.
And I was double up.
And as the book and I I graduate
we're gonna make you proud that
zero banking.
Some people falsely and the I
used to go to community.
Vocational services where I was.
The president of the south Latin
to see class and that.
My friend Lisa.
She took by place and I'm no
longer there.
And I decided.
After I left.
I want to still advocate for
these guys but allow higher
level because I'm the only guy.
You could tell by the White my
hair -- As
seen.
Of our the issues.
And concerns of the disabled
committee didn't what other the
rug. For very long time
[inaudible]
And since.
I'm a all the person --
I'm okay.
By the self.
I'm more concerned about the
snow goose.
Generation.
That's coming out now.
They're in the teens and in the
twenty of those who.
Have been born yet [inaudible]
En.
What I would like to see
[inaudible]
Is [inaudible]
Some funding. To the state
California.
Where?
Individuals with developmental
or physical.
Disabilities.
Especially those.
Who have?
Autism.
Or down syndrome.
State they can.
Get some type of vocational.
Training [inaudible]
Yeah.
Their has school or a trade
school or high aids case.
Survey can go out [inaudible]
News [inaudible]
In point [inaudible]
Much really [inaudible]
Gen [inaudible]
Society.
In the proud the could turn
[inaudible]
To the amenities.
En I like thank you for your
time.
And you don't take care.
With that your name and where
you're from please.
Hello my name's Corey cam nana
and nine grams social security
services.
And MS.
Am I several baby so I was born
on January twenty second.
Nineteen eighty nine head --
I have joined a lot of stuff.
There -- I
mean special antics --
I have gotten a lot of gold
ma'am medals.
And I had made.
Myself a girlfriend [inaudible]
Yes [inaudible]
Yes -- I
enjoy a lot.
They're and thank you for let me
be a part.
Of this [inaudible]
Wonderful.
People around me.
And thank you.
Make speaker please take your
name and where you're from.
Hello my name is Nick girls.
And visor a John Warner.
In.
Our nay.
Honolulu.
On earned.
And I'm.
June [inaudible]
Yeah of only --
As and and and then --
Me [inaudible]
And and and and our very very.
Very.
Very happy.
From her [inaudible]
Right.
Very nice job.
Thank speaker please enable your
from.
Hi -- My
name is Louise I'm from king
spurred but my son lives in a
group home in by Salia.
And like every proud mother I
would like you to see a picture
of my son.
Do you share that with them
please.
My son is the one with the black
cat -- This
is a recent picture my son on
his birthday.
And Jeff was born in nineteen
seventy three and as you heard
earlier --
Nineteen sixty nine was when
Ronald Reagan started making
changes for people with
disabilities.
And Jeff was born in.
Seventy three and he was born
right down the street.
At my workplace Fresno community
hospital.
And the pediatrician came to my
bedside a few hours after birth.
And the pediatrician explain
down syndrome.
And explains how the normal
course is to place the infants
in an institution [inaudible]
And then he said in the next
sentence now however there is
this brand new program called
the regional center.
And with this brand new program
there are numerous advantages
for your child [inaudible]
And adds the age of four four
days my husband and I were down
on Shaw Avenue signing papers.
For our son to be part of the
process for the regional center.
Tearful signing but we knew this
was in his best interest because
the alternative presented to us
was an institution --
So anyway CVR see has been part
of Jeff throughout his entire
life.
Infant stimulation early
education recreational
experiences work employment and
residential care.
See the R. C. has allowed Jeff
to Lee of in the least
restrictive environment.
And has allowed Jeff to reach
his full potential.
Throughout your life CVR city
has been available to me Jeff's
mother.
See if you are C. hasn't
reveille been available when
needed.
And I've learned that the
managers are also Ridley
available.
They are approachable and they
have a desire to resolve any
concerns that I may have.
I will give you one example.
Jeff had attended a creative
arts program for he learned to
be a stage performer.
And at and arts and I after
about. Seventeen years of this
program I received started
receiving calls from the program
manager about Jeff acting out.
Jeff for sherry the cookie at
lunch against rules.
Jeff was not coming in a bad
area day against roles.
And so I said to Jeff Jeff
what's going on Jeff being the
Wiseman he said.
I need a new boss.
So I said I can't change that
but you can go someplace else.
And he said I can.
I was so pleased I call the
regional center.
The case worker returned my call.
The next day I explore.
She was knowledgeable bill out
every sort of program Jeff could
attend.
In the Tulare county area.
She set up appointments for me
to go to these different places.
I narrowed it down.
To one then we took Jeff.
He loved it and he said I want
to go there and the case worker
sat down with him and says this
means you have different friends
you have different
transportation.
Your life will be different.
He understood because she took
time to talk to him the person.
And then this is a work program
so the now Jeff has a paycheck.
He's excited to earn thirty
dollars a week he's a proud man
in fact he said to his dad one
time dad.
I'm a man I have a paycheck.
But we have a couple speakers we
have to be out here okay so --
Basically I found a CV RC to be
people who care and people who
want to help.
They've been responsive.
And I'm grateful to share Jeff's
life with him.
I've always been grateful.
Jeff was born five years earlier.
Or he would not be with the city
of yours [inaudible]
Institution.
Every night champion I talk on
the phone.
How was your day?
And Jeff always answers my date
with -- Fate
[inaudible]
Your name.
And we're from within a couple
minutes.
Thank you for having me thank
you for being here many zeroes
Palos.
I am an advocate for disabled
American veterans and homeless.
And have a disability myself.
Day camp for the Senate --
Sent Central Valley for the
Brian they help me again how to
live.
House one of the best probably
athletes around here.
And I thank you Joaquin for
being with us on a stand up and
stand down over the success.
Cobb you will need and I'm
really scared for that
proposition.
Six if against repealed run
trouble Celestica Montana thank
you very much.
Internet where you're from.
My name is Rick and I'm from
Fresno and north for California.
And I've been doing this in some
form or another for forty seven
years.
And even when I was a paramedic
I took time off.
To I tend.
To what I loved.
We deal with that part of
society that's considered broken.
Were forgotten.
Or their swept under the rug.
And and I'm glad that we have.
You guys to come and actually
say this though.
All I wanna say is we need more
money for these [inaudible]
Programs --
So they don't get swept under
the rug they don't get forgotten
and they're not looked at as
broken.
So we need more money.
And more years like you guys
thank you.
Looks like this will be our last.
Please my name is Reza way moan
and I live in Fresno --
I'm just gonna be repeating a
lot of what everybody is sad --
I'd like to tell you a little
bit about my daughter.
She's thirty six years old she
works she works at a place that --
Values her gifts she's a big
contributor there and they would
miss her she wasn't there --
She's also looking for more work
all the time.
As other people to make ends
meet she lives in our own home.
And she's active in her
community there.
She probably knows more
neighbors than I do she does
favors for them and they look
after her --
She balling she's done volunteer
work -- She
shares her own story in fact
should be at the conference on
Thursday --
Participating in a panel --
She belongs to clubs she's now
the president of a club that she
is active in and none of this
happens without the support
without the support of the
agencies that are represented
here today.
They've all played a part --
All the advocacy agencies that
are here State Council
disabilities rights.
Regional center --
Has has.
Just I would echo what the young
man said I'm not sure what we
would have done without them --
And then that this would have
happened for her --
The community needs people
living with a disability to be
part of the community.
And one of the things that I I
want to and with is that --
Regional center has now
committed to becoming a person
centered thinking agency.
I have the privilege to be a
part of that project.
And the user trainings that are
ongoing for the staff there's
internal activities for the
staff to keep.
The vision going.
Of person centered planning.
And the trainings are not just
for the staff in the air it's
equally as important that is for
the community.
So these trainings are given out
in the community for parents for
providers.
And for anyone else that unity --
So we can see an inclusive hold
community in Fresno thank you.
I think I'm gonna let you have
the floor for a minute so you
can.
To show your feelings.
We will start if I can to thank
everybody who came but
specifically the mother from
kings park if I could --
Your comment about your son
ending with you his day being
perfect --
Reflects the feelings I have
about today as well.
There's times we can lose faith
in our democracy in what we do
by.
What we hear?
But there are moments like today
that I'm reaffirmed in what it
means to make our communities
better.
It's by advocates like you.
Who come forward and give voice
to the problems and the
disenfranchised?
And it's up to us the servant
public service to do something
about it.
And so I look forward to the
opportunities to working
collaboratively with all of you
who are here.
No I hold hearings through the
year and sub one and hope I see
many of you continuing to be
advocates in that form as well.
We need all of our forces we
need to all be rowing in the
right direction and working
together.
Without I just wanted to thank
again you Mister chair for
agreeing to hold this hearing
here.
It's imperative that we in the
valley feel like we get heard.
And I heard from many of you
today and was moved by what I
heard.
So thank you for making this a
perfect day.
With that --
I am blessed to serve in the
assembly with doctor Arambula
who is so passionate about.
The human being --
Coming to him as the chairman of
someone in being able.
To share with him some of the
issues that I've run across and
he's been so support of one of
the reasons that.
We were able to be able to work
on this committee together and a
passion for the people that you
and I and the doctor okay all
care about --
I can't thank you each and
everyone of you enough for being
here.
And sharing with us how we can
better advocate for you also.
Remember.
Your voice is being heard.
We are going to advocate on a
higher level but what I will
share with you.
As I mentioned dyslexia bill.
When we were going to the
process of getting this bill?
Through the committees.
The advocates the mothers showed
up.
There was a hundred mama bears
in this committee where these
lime green.
T. shirts and you think any
those committee members we're
going to opposed does mama bears.
You got to be the momma bear and
Papa bear.
In those committees.
That's how you're going to get
things pushed through
legislation we need your help
also.
We can be the voice.
And we can be the the
quarterback with the ball.
Be your the force to be reckoned
with.
We represent you.
No I have six more years the
doctor has eight I believe --
Left into in the assembly.
And to tell you the truth --
I'm gonna commit my next six
years and most of my legislation
to this community.
So working together.
We will be able to address the
needs.
And do it on a task with tactful.
Unemotional business like level
to go back towards.
The ministration tell them at
another has enough.
And as the one gentleman had --
Mentioned swept under the rug
will not happen ever again on my
watch.
I look forward.
To provide we have a survey on
my website for the intellectual
developing disabled how your
dealings with and not to pick on
the regional centers but we want
to know how the providers.
How the the regional centers
approach providing for the
families?
And we want to know how we can
actually support more through
funding in and and other
processes to go forward so we
look for you addressing the
website and and doing the survey.
But we're going to seven more of
these hearings throughout
California.
In December --
Dropping legislation in last
socially challenged each and
every member of of the
legislature in the assembly. To
carry at least one bill for the
IDG population that's eighty
bills right there [inaudible]
With that.
Thank you Fresno.
You've been heard.
Hey we will continue to advocate
for the IDG prop population and
take you to the regional centers
all the advocates.
We need more people are carrying
just like you thank you